[Musique]
comment il s'appelle manie écoute on va
faire tout ce qu'il faut pour t'aider à
retourner auprès de ton père
stop
où est ton père
fait de sortir je veux pas te flingue
chez moi alors qu'ils se barrent cas
elle ta fille et là pas de voir dans cet
état qu'est ce que tu fous là la
présentation au magasin et souvient
18 ans
il va pas s'en tirer comme ça
votre attention géré clients
très exactement une heure une série
d'explosions va réduire cet endroit
ensemble à moins de voir aux infos qu'un
procureur porte plainte contre le membre
du congrès sadness le magasin est à moi
ou m'appartenait tous désormais s'il te
plaît me bats pas
tu te sauver ma vie ils vont payer
on a beau me
je sais que tu m'écoutes espèces d'eaux
carré de fils de [ __ ]
ma
tous les jeunes avaient prévu
je lis prendre tout ce qu'il a même si
c'est la dernière chance le père
[Musique]
ils vendent des munitions ici tu sais
que tu peux avoir une réduc